je vais le détruire il est encore parlé
sur ma mère
ça peut faire mal
la Reine des Neiges
ça lui parle
sur le bloc de là c'est dire un truc
calme-toi quand même
dans l'autre sens Jordan le micro
[Musique]
j'en ai marre que tu parles de ma mère
comme dans le grand frère
pas possible j'en ai
ai marre j'ai eu la glace j'ai pas eu
mon whisky
[Applaudissements]
je lui en veux parce que tu as été il a
été méchant hier il était très
désagréable j'aurais pu être pire mon
petit bonhomme comment ça tu aurais pu
être pire j'ai une coloscopie de ta mère
[Applaudissements]
du bout de ma [__]
mais c'est un
[Applaudissements]
connards
tu sais que si j'enlève un B ça fait un
gars
oui mais faut enlever le B justement
hein
c'est une chambre c'est quoi c'est
ça la supérieux tu en as de luxe c'est
ça
[Applaudissements]
lui dire mais sans taper parce que tu
dis il y a du mieux avec ton cœur
[Applaudissements]
ça a fait de la peine ce que tu as dit
hier un texto même de Christine Bravo
non la pauvre
Christine qui m'a dit mais c'est quoi ce
bordel de faire insulter par un vieux
ringard sur TPMP
[Applaudissements]
tu sais pourquoi tu m'en veux
enlève tes lunettes regarde-moi dans les
yeux regarde-moi regarde-moi la merde
donne-moi la main donne-moi la main et
prends le miennes écoute-moi tu es
méchant parce que tu es malheureux
je voulais vous faire un bisou sur la
bouche
[__] mais c'est pas possible ils
comprennent rien c'est pas mal sur la
bouche il m'en veut mais je vais vous
dire pourquoi il m'en veut parce que la
dernière fois il est venu dans
l'émission et puis tu t'es énervé parce
que je t'ai foutu un passage je sais
plus qui t'avait énervé et tu as crié
machin et tout et tu as totalement
changé depuis parce que tu es depuis que
tu as rencontré Cyril c'est vrai tu es
devenu mais moi je trouve mes
connaissables oui oui et tu m'en avoues
je trouve ça si parce que tu as arrêté
sur tes réseaux de de communiquer le
passage où j'avais les narines gonflées
j'étais ridicule et ça et je te remercie
pour allez faites-moi bisous
[Applaudissements]